الان من صور تاتينا من شوارع مختلفه
لباريس لهذه المظاهرات حجم المشاركه فيها
يدفعنا للتساؤل عن مدى تاثير النقابات في
تحريك الشارع اليوم ما هو دور النقابات
والدور المنوط بها ايضا
[موسيقى]
النقابات لحد الان تعتمد بشكل كبير على
المظاهرات بدلا من كسر اقتصاد البلد لكن
اذا لم تقد هذه المظاهرات الى اي نتيجه
ملموسه هنالك خوف من انه قد يكون هنالك
غلق واعاقه للاقتصاد لم يحصل هذا الامر
ياتي في نهايه المطاف لدينا قد يكون هنالك
بعض الصعوبات في ايجاد ربما الوقود او
الماء او استخدام وسائل النقل يوما واحد
لكن ااا فرنسا لم تتوقف تماما هي ليست في
وضعي الفوضى لم تصل الى ذلك الوضع الى لحد
الان لكن المشكله هي انه في النقابات
والتي هي تقوم بحشد ربما اعضائها اذا ما
كان هنالك احتجاجات واضرابات كبرى سيخسرون
اجورهم في ايضا فان ازمه تكلفه المعيشه هي
في مقدمه ما يفكر به الناس وقد لا نجد
الكثير من الاشخاص يريدون ان يقوموا بهذه
الاضرابات ربما في القضايا الاساسيه ربما
الملحه لكن
حاليا باستطاعتنا ان نرى ان
النقابات ستفضل ان تدخل في مفاوضات لان
امر الاربعه وستين هو نوع من الخط الاحمر
لماكرون وهو خط احمر ايضا للنقابات ومن
الصعب ان نرى اذا ما كان سيكون هنالك
اتفاق بين الطرفين
تقديم نوع من التنازلات ربما سيظل عندما
يتم الطلب من الحكومه ان تكون اكثر مرونه
في تعاملها مع هذه المطالب وهذه النقابات
ما شكل هذه المرونه
اامرونا تبدو على شكل ربما
مثلا هنالك اشخاص يرغبون بالتقاعد قبل عمر
ال 64 وقد تتمثل باجراءات مثلا تخص اشخاص
تمكن الافراد من ان يتقاعدوا قبل حسب
رغبتهم وفي نهايه الحياه المهنيه ربما قد
يعملون لا يعملون لخمس ايام او لثلاث ايام
او قد يكون هنالك وظائف ربما لا تطالبهم
بجهد بدني بالتالي فان صعوبه الظروف العمل
خاصه عندما يكون هنالك اعمال ووظائف تتطلب
قوه بدنيه وبالتالي تجعل من الصعب على
الافراد ان يستمروا بهذه الوظائف بهذا
العمر بعمر ال 64 هذه امكانيه لكن في
نهايه المطاف كما
سابقا اذا
كانت النقابات مصره على ان عمر الاربعه
يجب ان يتم ابعاده
من هذه من هذا القانون والحكومه في نفس
الوقت
يصر على وضع هذا
العمر هل سيتمكنون من ايجاد ربما ارض وصلت
للتفاوض من الصعب الجزم في هذه المرحله
لان النقابات ما تزال تصر على التخلص من
هذا الرقم رقم 64 الخاص
بالعمر القانوني للتقاعد من باريس جاك
رولوم الباحث الاول بمعهد السياسه
العالميه والمتخصص
الحزبيه الفرنسيه ارجو ان تبقى مع